j'accueille maintenant les robins des
bois
les remballer moins que des robins des
bois marina foïs
bonsoir et jean paul rouve bonsoir je
vais raconter un petit peu votre vie 1 1
voilà les robins des bois se sont
rencontrés au cours d' isabelle nanty et
puits sans fond d'une troupe qui
s'appelait de rôle
imperial green rabbit compagnie et là
vous écrivez ensemble un spectacle qui
s'appelle robin des bois d'à peu près
alexandre dumas et c'est là que
dominique farrugia vous remarque et
quand il crée sa chaîne sur le câble et
le satellite comédie il vous engage
cette fois sous le nom des robins des
bois pour la grosse émission voilà ça va
durer deux ans deux ans de pur bonheur
et puis ensuite vous avez sur canal npa
là c'est un peu moins sympa pourquoi
mais parce que le public comprend mal
votre humour et ça se passe non je vais
m'intéresser
ça se passe très bien avec nagui qui
vous a assez souvent du programme non
non mais voilà non c'est pas ça non mais
ça se passait bien canal en plus à bord
s'est bien marré la nec nagui ça s'est
plutôt bien passé
c'est vrai qu'on était zapper
quelquefois en fin d'année abbas qui
avait du retard
pas bon d'accord qu'on a toujours et je
crois que malheureusement l'heure à
toute notre vie c'est que les gens ils
n'arrivent jamais à nous et mis tout de
suite je peux pas vous expliquer
pourquoi mais on a remarqué que les gens
commencent à avoir un petit peu de
tendresse pour nous au bout de 70 72
sketches mais jamais avant
il faut tenir les 72 bon ça allait mieux
quand même l'année d'après avec du
jambon c'était l'année de l'instant
norvégien dont vous sortez un best-of en
cassettes et dvd vous savez comment on
fait